Human caused Global Warming is basically an
accepted fact in most parts of said globe.
147 countries have signed and ratified the
Paris Agreement, meaning they’re taking
steps to keep the climate from warming more
than 2 degrees celsius from pre-industrial
levels.
But one of the biggest polluters has just
announced they’re backing out of the agreement.
Can you guess who that is?
That’s right.
It’s us.
Or the U.S., if you’re not us.
And while that will be catastrophic for the
world because of the whole sea level rise
and droughts and hurricanes thing, it could
also be a serious blunder for the U.S. economically.
Saving the planet means changing how we produce
and use energy.
Two favorite alternative sources are solar
and wind.
If the whole world is going to want these
renewables, then whoever can make the best,
cheapest, most efficient solar panels or wind
turbines will win.
It’s a wind-win, if you will.
And that brings us back to the United States,
and our will-they-or-won’t they relationship
with accepting climate change.
While other nations invest tens and even hundreds
of billions in renewables, we could be stuck
offering a product that nobody wants anymore.
Eventually if we do come around, we’ll likely
have to rely on importing technology that
was developed elsewhere.
Considering an American invented the solar
cell in 1941, that’s a heck of a lead to
blow.
So, if we’re not taking the lead on this,
who is?
China.
China has plenty of coal to meet their needs,
so you might think they, like coal and natural
gas loving America, would be inclined to keep
on burning.
But Chinese cities are famously polluted,
and it’s hard to ignore when cities of 10s
of millions of people ask if they can just
breathe a little bit better, please?
China has answered in a big way.
They started with a 5 year plan to raise wind
output nearly 63 percent and more than double
solar production by 2020.
They’re also constructing 20 new nuclear
power plants with more planned, using and
improving on technology from the west.
According to one report, they could spend
as much as $782 Billion dollars to meet their
emission targets by 2030.
Why isn’t the US following suit?
In a word, politics.
Somehow climate science has become a partisan
issue over here, and conservatives tend to
write it off as a liberal cause.
Many conservatives see solutions to global
warming as something that could hurt the economy.
Basically, environmental restrictions can
get in the way of businesses doing business.
However, there are some on the right that
see an economic opportunity with solving some
issues surrounding man-made global warming.
Debbie Dooley, a founder of the far right
Tea Party, is a big advocate for solar power
and has gotten bans on solar lifted in Georgia
because she believes consumers should have
a choice.
James Cason, the republican mayor of Coral
Gables, Florida believes people everywhere
should worry about sea level rise because
of how much of our economy is dependent on
goods coming in and out of ports.
Even if you don’t believe in climate change,
investing in renewable energy is the smart
thing to do.
It’s what the rest of the world is demanding,
and the first rule of sales is to give the
people what they want.
Investing in solar and wind could not only
save the world as we know it, but we could
make a buck while we’re at it.
What’s more American than that?
Environmentalism may be a partisan issue now,
but it didn’t use to be this way.
Matt Morales follows how we got to this point
in his video here.
Even if you’re a climate skeptic, do you
still think it’s worth investing in green
technology?
Let us know in the comments, like and subscribe
for more, and thanks for watching Seeker.